BJÖRNFOT FIRES IT IN
GETTING AN OPPORTUNITY ON THE
NUMBERSPACE, GOES
UP TIED, NET OFF THE MOORINGS AE
WAS NOTSHOT'S WIDE
AS THE HABS HAVE HIT AROT
HANGS IN B B
TWO SHOTS ON CALVIN PETERSEN AS.
THAT'S A ONE HAND, PUTS HIS
STICK IN THE RIGHT HAND, UP ON
BRENDAN LEMIEUX COMES IN AND
SNIPES HIS FIRST GOAL OF THE
SEASON, HIS FIRST POINT AND
WE'RE LEVEL AT ONE.
YOU LIKE JAKE ALLEN TO MAKE THEE
ATHA
DANAULT COMES A LITTLE FLIPPER,
GETS THE SPATULA T
LOOSE, RIGHT AT THE CREA
IAFALLO MAKES IT A 2-1 HOCKEY
GAME. A LITTLE RUSH
EVANS.
AN
RACES, THAT'S GOOD.
HERE'S EDLER.
THAT WAS AHAT IS AS NICE ASLOOST
IN TIGHT AND
PASS DRIVE AND PUT IT UNDER THE
INFORMATION.
TOFFOLI SHOOTS ON THAT, TYLER
KEPT IT OUT OF  WRIST SHOT
AND THAT GREY PART OF THE BAR,P
WIDEMAN.
HOFFMAN WRIST SHOT, REBOUND AND
SO OVERTIME COMING IN A 2-2 TIE
IAFALLO, HOFFMAN, DVORAK, PETRY.
UNDER W BACKHAND.
THE
>> Mike: A PRETTY NICE PIVOT BY
ROY TO STAY WITH HIM ANDRISTIAN
PETERSEN!
END TO END ACTION,O KEEP IT AND
HIS OPTIONSL.A. KINGS HAVE NOW
STRAIGHT GAMES!